hello hello people beyond the camera
that we're looking at yes we're here to
rule your world but first let's get to
the questions we have the Goblet of Fire
thank God would you rather have to wear
a super tool wizard's hat every day for
the rest of your life or wear Wizards
cloak with every outfit I know your
answer both some people actually do
where is it every day every day
rook me and Shoreditch that stuff
happens I mean if I was required it
would give me an excuse I've seen you
overcook it would you rather be the true
master of the Elder Wand or be the owner
of the invisibility cloak Elder Wand
Elder Wand whoa invisibility cloak is
pretty dope thing to have cloak Munchkin
Horace
they're just like big cooler you a
unicorn but invisibility cloak I can
just go steal pizza pizza places no but
then you know in the original mythology
elder one and you've got the elder one
that everyone's after you at the Elder
Wand and they want to fight you what
what would you do it like girl Rumpy was
house is rather get to explore newts
case or Dumbledore's office stumble
about this I've been in this case been
there done that sneak a peek
Dumbledore's sneak of scopes I
understand that totally in that case is
kind of stinking
newts case yeah sure would you rather
face a boggart without magic or face
Dement or with
we'll choose Bogart this is just but
it's a deep question and it plays into a
lot of what your sense of fear is but I
don't know Matt situation sorry you know
these questions uh I'd say bugger I'd
rather just be like you're right there
is nothing there's nothing to fear but
fear itself
rather than be like there's the thing
I'm gonna suck my soul out of my body
like oh I don't have any Patronus juice
no no no would you rather be a performer
at the circus archanis or be one of
Grindelwald followers this question is
for you guys I mean I'm already a
performer this arcade think like you're
more thoroughly entrapped as one of men
of all its followers because you're in
the clutch of a silvertone would you
rather fight one Rompin sighs nefler or
100 Nikolas sighs aramas probably one
you could also you can like focus on one
thing like that's a lot and like where
do you look friends what kind of file an
emotional fire you're like you let's
talk through this there's so many really
you know this is magical because listen
okay would you rather have Queenie's
mind-reading power or be able to turn
invisible like it ever goes
I mean I think reading people's can't
you turn it off
can you turn it off in disability this
time yeah the whole constant
mind-reading thing is obviously a curse
seeker see gift that seems exhausting it
feels like you live in Twitter I don't
want to be there I don't even want to be
in my own head half the time so I guess
that me guys would you rather live your
life and the Wizarding World would not
be able to do magic or just never know
magic existed is this specifically to me
that's not asking me would I like to be
myself or something else a muggle in
everything is about acceptance I think
I'd rather live in the Wizarding World
and not be able to do magic it'd be it'd
be but at least I'd be able to witness
that's like not knowing love just like
not knowing a cool summer wind I believe
in magic anyway so but you didn't you
wouldn't know it existed no I do know
that was a question in a jewel would you
rather stun or disarm an opponent Stan I
like the stun stupefy you like
[Laughter]
[Music]